of course I have nothing against the
fact that your boss treats you in a nice
way and so on the problem is if this not
only covers up the actual relationship
of power but makes it even more
impenetrable you know if you have a boss
who is up there the old fashioned boss
shouting at you exerting full brutal
Authority in a way it's much easier to
rebel then to have a friendly boss who
embraces you or how us was the last
night with your girlfriend blah blah all
that body stuff where then it almost
appears impolite to protest but I will
give you an example an old story that I
often use to make it clear what do I
mean by this
imagine you or me we are I'm a small boy
it's Sunday afternoon my father wants me
to visit our grandmother let's say my
father is a traditional authority what
would he be doing he'll probably tell me
something like I don't care how you feel
it's your duty to visit your grandmother
be polite to her and so on nothing bad
about this
I claim because I can still repel and so
on it's a clear order but what would a
so called the so called post modern
modern non authoritarian father do I
know because I experienced it he would
have said something like this you know
how much your grandmother loved you but
nonetheless I'm not forcing you to visit
her
you should only visit her if you freely
decide to do it now every child knows
that beneath the appearance of free
choice there is a much stronger pressure
in this second message because basically
your father is not only telling you you
must visit your godmother but you must
love to visit it it's euro he tells you
how you must feel about it it's a much
stronger
orders and I think that this is for me
almost a paradigm of modern permissive
Authority this is why the formula of
totalitarianism is not I don't care what
you think just do it this is traditional
authoritarianism the totalitarian
formula is I know better they knew what
you really want and I may appear to be
forcing you to do it but I'm really just
making you do what without fully knowing
you want and so on and so on so in this
sense yes I am horrified by this also
another aspect this new culture of
experts where an injunction is presented
just as a neutral statement for example
one example that I like and let's not
have a misunderstanding here I don't
smoke and I am for punishing tobacco
companies and so on and so on but I'm
deeply suspicious about our phobia about
smoking I don't buy it the dis can be
really justified just based on
scientific knowledge how cigarettes
earth hurt us and so on and so on
because my first problem is that most of
the people who oppose smoking then
usually are for legalization of drugs
and so on and so on but my basic problem
is this one look now they found a more
or less solution e cigarettes electronic
cigarettes and I discovered that now I'm
a big American airline companies decided
to prohibit them and it's interesting to
read the reason why the reason it's not
so much that is not yet sure are they
safe or not basically they are the idea
is that if you smoke during the flight a
cigarette you publicly display your
addiction and that it's not a good
pedagogical example for others and so on
and so on I mean I find this a clear
example of how a certain ethic which is
not just neutral ethics
of health but basically I think it's
ethics of don't don't fall into it don't
have a too passionate engagement remain
at the proper distance control yourself
and so on and now I will shock you to
end I think even racism can be ambiguous
here you know once I made an interview
when I was asked how do we find
reactionary racism you know what must
buy answer with progressive racism then
what do you mean of course I didn't mean
racism what I meant is the following
things of course racist jokes and so on
can be extremely oppressive humiliating
and so on but the solution I think is to
create an atmosphere or to practice
these jokes in such a way that they
really function as that little bit of
obscene contact which establishes
through proximity between us and I'm
talking from my own past political
experience ex-yugoslavia
I remember when I was young when I met
from other when I met with other people
from ex-yugoslavia public circus crowd
Bosnia's and so on we were all the time
take telling dirty jokes about each
other but not so much against the other
we were in a wonderful way competing who
will be able to tell a national joke
about ourselves this were obscene racist
jokes but the effect was a wonderful
sense of shared obscene solidarity and I
have another proof here do you know that
when Civil War exploded in Yugoslavia
early 90s and already before in the
eighties ethnic tensions the first
victim with these drugs they immediately
disappeared because people felt very
well that for example what let's say I
visit another country I say this
politically correct respect you what is
your food what are your cultural forums
no I tell them tell me
a dirty joke about yourself and we will
be friends and so on it works so you see
this ambiguity Dex my problem with with
political correctness now it's just a
form of self-discipline which doesn't
really allow you to overcome racism
it's just oppressed controlled racism
and the same goes here I will tell you a
wonderful story simple once it happened
to me a year ago around the corner here
in the bookstore I was signing a book of
mine two black guys came
african-americans I don't like the term
my black friend also not because for
obvious reasons it can be even more
racist but the point is and they asked
me to sign a book and seeing them there
I couldn't resist the worst racist
remark when I was returning the books to
them I told them you know now I don't
know which one is for whom you know you
blacks like yellow guys you look all the
same they embraced me and they told me
you can call me nigger you know when
they tell you this it means we are
really close they instantly got this on
another stupid problem I had at some
talk
there was a mutant deaf guy and he asked
if a translator can be there to tell and
I couldn't resist it in the middle of
the talk in front of two 300 people I
said what are you doing there guys my
idea was if you watch the gestures of
the translator it looked to me as a some
obscene messages or what the guy laughed
so much we become friends not own and
some old stupid lady reported me for
making fun of crippled people it was so
didn't you see that's how I became
friends with a guy but I'm wait a minute
now I'm not an idiot I'm well aware this
doesn't mean we should just walk around
and humiliate each other it's a great
art how to do it I'm just saying that my
hypothesis without such an tiny exchange
of friendly obscenities you don't get a
real contact with another it
is this cold respect and so on you know
we need this we need this to establish a
real contact this is what is lacking for
me in political correctness and then you
end up in madness like it's not a joke I
check job with my Australian friends you
know what happened in Perth the West
Coast Australian City
it's not a joke I repeated the Opera
House they're prohibited staging of
Carmen opera Carmen you know why because
the first act takes place in front of a
tobacco factory I'm not kidding I'm not
kidding I'm I'm just saying that there
is something so fake about about
political correctness it's I know it's
better than open racism of course but I
wonder if it works because you know I
never for example bought all this
permanent replacement you know nigger
sir Negros Negros are black okay
black and African Americans maybe it's
up to them to decide the only only thing
I know is that when I was in Missoula
Montana I got engaged in a very friendly
conversation with some Native Americans
they hate the term and they gave me a
wonderful reason they told me Native
American and you are cultural American
so what we are part of nature they told
me we'd much prefer to be called Indians
at least our name is a monument to white
men stupidity who thought there in India
when they come here and they said such a
wonderful insight into how all this new
age you know we white people
technologically exploit nature while
Native relate to nature in a dialogic
way like before they dig into Earth Day
ash the mountain for permission if
they're mining blah blah they told me
that the research shows that Native
American Indians
much more buffaloes and burned much more
forest than white people you know why
this was the correct point like the
message was the most racist thing is to
patronizingly elevate us in that you
know primitive organic living together
with modern nature now the fundamental
right is to be evil also if we can be
evil why shouldn't they be evil and so
on not so again even with racism one has
to be very precise not to fight racism
in a way which ultimately reproduces is
not directly racism itself at least the
conditions for places